[Musique]
pour voler l'empire
dans lequel vous entrez comme si vous apparteniez
[Musique]
ils sont si fiers d'eux-mêmes,
si gros et satisfaits
qu'ils ne peuvent pas imaginer
quelqu'un comme moi
[Musique]
qui entrerait un jour dans leur  house
cassian ander
l'empire nous étouffe si lentement que
nous commençons à ne pas remarquer
ce que je demande, c'est
que tu ne préférerais pas tout donner
à quelque chose de réel
[Musique]
j'ai besoin de tous les héros que je peux obtenir
pour le plus grand bien
appelez ça comme vous voulez appelons ça la
guerre
ça fermente là-bas des
poches de fermentation
tu es dans mon filet
es-tu un poisson
ou es-tu un voleur
tu glisses
je ne dors pas
je me cache depuis trop longtemps
tant que tout le monde pense que je suis une
irritation
il y a de fortes chances qu'ils ratent ce que
je fais vraiment qu'est-ce que tu
fais
vraiment c'est à quoi ressemble la révolution j'en
ai marre de te perdre